[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous ce flash spécial pour
vous annoncer c'est très spectaculaire
explosion se serait un attentat selon
les médias américains à new york au
coeur de manhattan
en vous découvrez l'image en l'espace de
20 minutes deux avions ont percuté les
prestigieux tours jumelles du world
trade center donc dans le quartier de
wall street en plein jour à 20h45 heure
américaine
les tours sont en feu vous l'avez vu pas
de bilan pour l'instant on parle de
plusieurs morts au moins et de dizaines
de blessés puisque à ce moment de la
journée
ces bureaux du quartier de wall street
sont déjà bien sûr occupé attentat selon
les télévisions américaines selon un
haut responsable américain également le
temps était très clair en voit mal
comment un accident aurait pu se
produire dans de telles conditions et
surtout surtout il y a
cette suite c'est deux avions qui donc
en l'espace de 18 minutes exactement se
sont encastrées en quelque sorte dans
ces deux tours provoquant une explosion
et un incendie
on va tout de suite revenir sur le film
des événements avec thierry curtet puis
on va évoquer bien entendu les premières
hypothèses se sont bien sûr ce sont bien
deux avions qui se sont abattues sur
chacune des deux tours du world trade
center de new york
ici sur cette image le deuxième appareil
qui vient percuter la deuxième tour les
twin sisters et deux tours jumelles
véritable monument historique de
manhattan sont le symbole de la toute
puissance financière et commerciale de
l'amérique
il semble que le premier appareil soit
un boeing 737 un avion commercial un
avion de ligne donc
et d'après les premières constatations
du fbi haye l'avion n'a pas dévié de sa
trajectoire il semble bien qu'il se soit
délibérément jeté sur la tour et ses 18
minutes plus tard qu'un autre appareil
est venu percuter lui aussi la deuxième
tour sur ces images filmées depuis un
hélicoptère
les
tours sont en flammes il y aurait eu
d'après le fbi haye une prise d'otage
quelques minutes auparavant sur l'un des
deux appareils
l' agence fédérale était semble-t-il en
liaison avec cet avion
la première explosion a eu lieu vers
20h50 c'est à dire 14h45 heure de paris
ces deux immeubles abrite de nombreux
bureaux prestigieux et stratégique de
nombreuses multinationales
particulièrement surveillés depuis un
premier attentat islamiste
en 1993 voilà grâce donc à l'ensemble
des journalistes de france 3 des
reporters nous essayons depuis donc le
milieu de l'après-midi de vous tenir au
courant au fur et à mesure des
développements de apprécié triple
attentat donc à new york et à washington
nous allons refaire un point complet de
toutes les informations dont nous
disposons à la fois en information et
puis des images et de nouvelles images
qui sont d'ailleurs arrivés il ya peu de
temps en temps quand quelques minutes
new york a donc vécu un véritable
cauchemar il faut préciser qu'à cette
heure de la matinée entre 8h30 et 9h
delà des 9 heures le quartier de
manhattan est déjà en pleine activité
notamment donc dans l'eau ces deux tours
du world trade center ou quarante mille
personnes travaillent vous allez vivre
cette terrifiante attaque terroriste sur
new york en images avec pascal justice
la scène est plus incroyable que le
scénario de la tour infernale
tout a commencé ce matin à 8h40 3 à new
york
une première explosion a retenti en
plein manhattan
un avion de ligne avec 58 passagers à
son bord vient de heurter l'une des
tours du world trade center la
télévision américaine braque sa caméra
sur la tour en feu caen 18 minutes plus
tard un second avion apparaît dans le
ciel
il s'agit cette fois d'un boeing 767
d'american airlines détourné depuis
boston avec 81 passagers à son bord
il va percuter la tour jumelle de plein
fouet en direct devant les
téléspectateurs du monde entier
l'explosion est terrible à l'intérieur
prisonniers des flammes les gens
appellent au secours
certains cèdent à la panique et décide
de sauter dans le vide
s'ensuivent des scènes de détresse et de
panique collective dans les rues new
yorkaises
alors que le maire fait évacuer tout le
sud de manhattan
j'étais au 36e étage quand ça s'est
produit
c'était comme un tremblement de terre
jacques chirac
l'immeuble était secoué tout trembler
tout est tombé par la fenêtre serment
croyable dans un nuage de fumée
gigantesque le building le plus célèbre
du monde va maintenant s'effondrer
il est 10 heures heure locale la
première tour s'écroule après avoir
brûlé pendant plus d'une heure une demi
heure plus tard sa jumelle se désintègre
entièrement 40000 personnes
travaillaient à l'intérieur nul ne sait
combien ont péri des milliers de blessés
ont été dirigés vers les hôpitaux sous
un nuage de cendres j'ai regardé vers le
haut et j'ai vu le bâtiment s'écroule et
sur la ville tous les gens de la rue se
sont arrêtés et on pleurait c'était
vraiment la panique
il ya eu d'énormes explosions on ne
voyait plus rien on aurait dit une
tempête de neige et on a compris que ce
n'était pas de la neige que ça venait du
building
c'est un cauchemar le bilan humain ne
sera pas connue avant 24 heures en
revanche on estime déjà les dégâts
matériels à plusieurs millions de
dollars
nous voici dans les sous sols du world
trade center juste au dessus du métro
new yorkais qui à cette heure était
bondée et voilà en surface ce qu'il
reste des deux tours jumelles
symbole de la puissance américaine ce
soir new york ressemble à une ville en
guerre
dévasté par un bombardement incroyable
inimaginable
hallucinant les mots font défaut pour
qualifier la très vaste
la très spectaculaire opération
terroriste mené aujourd'hui on va
d'abord revivre les événements le
pentagone bien sûr et surtout c'est
tours immenses du world trade center
percutées de plein fouet par deux avions
de ligne détournés
on a cru d'abord un accident la panique
et l'incrédulité images commentées par
thierry kurt elle
l'image est effroyable un premier avion
a déjà percuté la première tour un
deuxième appareil se présente il vise et
percute l'autre tours jumelles du world
trade center
il est 9h 14 à new york le boeing n'a
pas dévié sa trajectoire d'un seul
maître transformer en kamikaze
il se crashe sur le symbole de la toute
puissance économique américaine les
prestigieuses twin towers de new york
quarante minutes plus tard à washington
un troisième avion s'écrase sur le
pentagone
le plus stratégique de tous les
bâtiments militaires américains puis un
quatrième appareil à 747 s'écrase en
pennsylvanie
ces quatre avions de ligne détournés
provenaient de trois villes différentes
et transportait 2 166 passagers à new
york
les deux avions transformé en missile
ont percuté les deux tours au moment de
l'arrivée au bureau des 50000 personnes
qui travaillait au world trade center
des dizaines d'employés font des signes
désespérés
d'autres vont choisir de se jeter par
les fenêtres
les deux bâtiments jumeaux mesure plus
de 400 mètres de haut mais les deux
tours véritable monument de new york ne
vont pas résisté bien longtemps
la première se brise par le milieu
bascule et s'effondre la seconde
quelques minutes plus tard implose et
s'écroule
chacun des deux bâtiments peser plus de
300 mille tonnes située au bord d'une
rivière d'un côté mais adossé au
quartier des affaires de wall street de
l'autre le maire de new york parle d'un
effroyable bilan sans annoncer le
moindre chiffre
l'aviation civile américaine décide de
fermer tous les aéroports des états unis
ou d'un avion civil est autorisé à voler
les trains doivent rester en gare les
frontières avec le canada et le mexique
sont bouclés et marchés financiers en
chute libre fermé
l'amérique est paralysé
j stick très développé vous parliez de
1000 hommes pendant 1 an
xavier raufer antoine basbous vous avez
l'impression os x une opération comme ça
elle est forcément préparé depuis
plusieurs mois et avec une logistique
très importante
bin laden a l'habitude d'espacé c'est
ses frappes mais de frapper très fort
rappelez-vous 95 arrêt à 96 aruba contre
les américains et puis 98 contre les
deux ambassades américaines à nairobi et
adhère et à dar es salaam et puis
l'année dernière en octobre 2000 il a
frappé lui ss cole c'est à dire un
bâtiment de guerre à aden au yémen
donc ils annoncent ils dans sa
littérature il avait dit le grand satan
ce sont des états unis suivie de la
grande bretagne et d'israël voilà qui
sont mes adversaires qui jacky je vais
m'attaquer
il a dit il y à une alliance judéo
croisé qui colonisent le territoire
sacré de l'islam en arabie il faut les
en chasser ccc pardonnez moi
l'expression un peu triviale c'est le
mobile c'est le mobilier la situation
mondiale mobile il y as pour bin ladin
bourg bin laden une doctrine la mecque
est occupé par les américains parce
qu'ils ont des bases en arabie il faut
les en chasser et puis al-aqsa est
occupée par les juifs
il faut les en chasser il y a des
précédents les américains ont fui le
vietnam et ont fui beyrouth en 81 points
ont fui la somalie et ses 200 dans son
discours dans ses argumentaires et du
coup on va les attaquer pour les faire
fuir
et c'est ça il cherche l'humiliation il
veut donner du moral aux islamistes et
il faut pas confondre islamistes et
islam et musulmans mais pourquoi
aujourd'hui alors que bien sûr il ya ce
regain de tension au proche orient mais
j'allais dire si cette opération demande
une préparation de plusieurs mois
c'était bien avant qu'elle a été décidée
françois heisbourg cette opération est
d'un tout autre ordre que toutes celles
qui ont précédé en a franchi alors on a
franchi un vrai seuil on est passé du
terrorisme à l'hyper terrorisme c'est le
premier acte d'hyper terrorisme dans le
monde c'est un basculement d'ordre
stratégique
encore une fois le bilan humain
sera nettement plus lourd que celui de
pearl harbour qui le parallèle qui est
générale et 1100 membres ou leur est
permis seulement le parallèle qui est
fait et à juste titre les etats-unis se
mobiliseront d'ailleurs j'en suis
certain en conséquence est que ce soit
bin laden ou d'autres il a fallu
beaucoup de temps pour organiser cette
opération
il y aura dans la recherche des
responsabilités une mise sur la sellette
de la chaîne du renseignement aux états
unis les services de renseignements sur
lesquels les américains dépensent à peu
près 20 milliards de dollars par an le
retour sur investissement aujourd'hui ne
paraît pas prêt mais pour vous le mot
ville françois heisbourg la raison
pourquoi aujourd'hui pourquoi maintenant
pourquoi comme ça elle il a fallu
beaucoup de temps pour l'organiser bin
laden ah si j'ose dire un vieux
contentieux avec les etats-unis
d'antoine basbous a rappelé parfaitement
a rappelé parfaitement les termes et
c'est bien pour cela que je pense qu'il
s'agit d'un groupe non étatiques qui
début que par des impératifs idéologique
et non pas par des enjeux territoriaux
ou des enjeux de pouvoir politique seul
un groupe de ce type l'an peut oser
franchir ce type de pas mais il a essayé
pour le millénaire il a envoyé deux
hommes deux algériens via le canada pour
frapper atlanta ils ont été capturés et
depuis ils continuent à affiner son son
mode opérationnel et là il a réussi un
très grand coup l aurent boussier est
avec nous en duplex de londres laurent
vous avez des informations parce qu'il
ya là bas un journal arabe dont un
journaliste est rentré en contact avec
quelqu'un qui connaît bien oussama ben
laden absolument je ne sais pas si ce
sont des informations mais c'est en tout
cas une piste
le rédacteur en chef du journal alcott
qui est quelqu'un qui semble avoir ses
entrées auprès de oussama ben laden a
rencontré il ya quelques jours un
journaliste pakistanais qui appartient à
la chaîne de télévision middle east
broadcasting qui est une chaîne
saoudienne
ces journalistes pakistanais auraient
rencontré oussama ben laden début
juillet vous avez mis en haleine qui lui
aurait affirmé je cite qu'il lui aurait
annoncé par l'onp a affirmé mme et
annoncé des actes à des attaques
spectaculaires qui toucherait les
intérêts américains
allez encore une fois c'est une
information à prendre avec un petit peu
de recul mais en tout cas c'est
certainement une
c'est parce que ces journalistes sont
des gens qui normalement sont assez bien
informés particulièrement sur qu'oussama
ben laden
merci laurent il ya quelque chose quand
même de frappant dans cet attentat qui
va j'allais dire au delà d'une lutte
idéologique
ça ressemble au méchant de james bond
dans sa démesure cet attentat renvoie
une folie humaine est ce que ben laden
est un fou si c'est lui bien sûr
est-ce qu'il ya effectivement cette
dimension-là cette dimension mégalomane
dans ce dans ce personnage
il ya deux constantes qu'on a tendance à
oublier la première c'est que les
conflits au moyen-orient se passe
toujours de la même manière depuis 45 ou
50 ans il y à des phases comme les
battements d'un coeur où les choses se
concentre au moyen-orient et la un
moment donné elles sont bloquées
alors après ça ça explose soit à
l'échelle de l'europe soit les chefs du
reste du masters et pour le mobile voilà
et deuxièmement n'oubliez pas que les
terroristes issus du moyen-orient' est
toujours un nouveau président des états
unis quand il arrive le premier oil 13
attente est ce vraiment là dans nos
maisons
voilà donc aller on est maintenant à
l'échelle plus les choses sont bloquées
au moyen-orient et plus ça explose fort
à l'extérieur on a concentré une espèce
de marmites de sorcières et maintenant
l'explosion est ce qu'on n'est pas au
delà tous avec cet attentat dans sa
démesure dans sa folie on est dans un
comportement qui ne peut être que le
comportement d'un groupe sans racines au
sens le plus strict du terme toutes
entités étatiques doivent veiller à des
impératifs de pouvoir éveiller des
impératifs de sécurité du territoire et
les états du moyen-orient ne sont pas
plusieurs rationnel que d'autres même
s'ils ne sont pas forcément plaisant
c'est fini depuis la fin de la guerre
est précisément quand même le sol
pendant terrorisme des normes définies
depuis les airs face en est la façon
dont les responsables de cet attentat en
tenter d'instrumentaliser avec un
certain succès hélas des palestiniens en
faisant revendiquer la sphère
initialement
faussement parle fdpl paix organisations
palestiniennes
les scènes de liesse qui s'en sont
suivies les malheureux palestiniens il
avait déjà sharon maintenant risque en
plus d'avoir la haine inextinguible de
la population américaine ayant assisté à
la télévision à ces scènes de liesse
jose j'ose espérer qu'elle est
responsable palestinien calmeront
maximum le jeu alors précisément antoine
basbous vous allez vous exprimer à
nouveau mais on va aller à jérusalem ont
retrouvé la mifi avi pazner l'un des
porte parole du gouvernement israélien
avi pazner est ce qu'on a le sentiment
là bas est ce que vous avez le sentiment
que c'est un attentat c'est une escalade
qui est lié au conflit proche oriental
mais nous avons remarqué que
immédiatement après l'attentât
un groupe palestinien on a clamé la
responsabilité après une heure ou deux
cela a été démenti
après nous avons contacté complice avec
trice presse que à jérusalem est
des palestiniens danser dans les rues
mais tout cela ce n'est pas une
information solide pour savoir qui est
derrière ces attentats
j'aimerais juste fait remarquer que
préparer un attentat comme ça cela prend
des mois sinon des années et que
contrairement à ce qui a été dit
maintenant par un de vos commentateurs
il est peu probable qu'une décision
comme cela et puis se faire en deux ou
trois semaines
cela est une affaire préparer manigancé
de longue date
vous sous-entendez que cette décision-là
de frapper de frapper cette manière là
n'auraient pas de lien avec l'attaqué
qui avait visé le leader du fplp cette
composante du fatah de yasser arafat est
ce que vous pensez ce soir monsieur
partenaires et que le danger le danger
terroriste pour israël a monté d'un cran
le danger terroriste pas seulement pour
israël ce qui est arrivé aux etats-unis
encore une fois je le répète nous ne
savons pas encore qui est derrière cette
attaque démontre que la terreur n'a pas
de logique
ce qui est arrivé aujourd'hui au
états unis est tout simplement
monstrueux et démesurée par tous les
critères humains et cela peut
malheureusement arriver pas seulement
israël mais dans d'autres pays aussi
si on ne prend pas les mesures
nécessaires pour combattre le terrorisme
vous avez proposer votre aide aux états
unis est ce que cela signifie que vous
avez des pistes des moyens d'en
connaître un peu plus sur ces groupes et
notamment sur l'entourage d'oussama ben
laden
donc nous avons proposé notre aide par
un mouvement spontané de solidarité et
d'amitié de compassion envers les états
unis et nous avons maintenant déjà des
équipes de sauvetage grec à s'envoler
vers les états unis dès qu'ils auront
reçu le feu vert
ça ne veut pas dire que nous avons une
piste sur qui a fait cela mais ça veut
dire que nous aimerions aider nos amis
américains dans cette heure de détresse
et dans cette tourmente dans laquelle
ils se trouvent et nous voulons faire
tout notre possible pour faciliter la
situation des blessés et de tous ceux
qui ont été atteints parfait pâques
nous allons maintenant entendre une
nouvelle série de réactions réaction de
new yorkais qui se trouvait à proximité
de l'endroit où a eu lieu le double
attentat
cet après midi on écoute ses réactions
l'angoissé le désarroi la population de
new york est sous le choc
les deux avions viennent de s'écraser
sur les tours du world trade center
les forces de police ont ordonné
l'évacuation de tout le sud de manhattan
des centaines de milliers de personnes
qui travaillaient où résidait dans le
centre de new york ont dû quitter les
lieux à pied pour se diriger vers le
nord de l'île les téléphones sont en
panne le métro est fermée les gens sont
obligés de rentrer chez eux à pied
c'est incroyable toute la ville est sous
le choc les gens déambuler se regardent
certains pleurent c'est incroyable je
pense que ces buildings aurait dû être
mieux protégés
ce sont les parce que c'est un centre
d'intérêt énorme c'est un symbole
nous ne savons pas qui a fait ça c'est
sans doute une organisation terroriste
qui est responsable de tout cela
tender après ces attaques on est en
mesure maintenant de reconstituer assez
précisément le déroulement des
événements en clair le détournement
concertée pratiquement simultanée de
quatre avions de ligne transformé donc
en bombes volantes dominique verdeilhan
agnès garder peur sur la ville un avion
survole manhattan un caméraman saisit
alors cette image hors du commun
un boeing 767 vient de percuter l'un des
building du world trade center
la tour est en flammes les secours
s'organisent accidents aériens ou
attentats l'amérique l'ignorent encore à
8h56 le vol 11 d'american airlines parti
de boston n'atteindra jamais los angeles
à son bord 80 passagers et 11 membres
d'équipage
18 minutes plus tard alors que les
télévisions du monde entier ont
interrompu leurs programmes
un deuxième avion s'encastre à son tour
dans l'autre building un second crash
lui aussi filmé par de nombreuses
caméras
[Applaudissements]
au fond
le vol 77 d'american airlines parti de
washington n'arrivera jamais à los
angeles à son bord 58 passagers
six membres d'équipage new york est
plongé dans un film catastrophe les
secours assistent impuissants à des
scènes d'horreur à certaines fenêtres
des employés font des signes désespérés
dérisoire d'autres choisissent le grand
saut
[Rires]
c'est l'exode de panique la thèse de
l'attentât terroriste ne fait aucun
doute sur leur écran de contrôle les
aiguilleurs du ciel ont été témoins des
deux détournements des boeing d'american
airlines
les équipages ont été probablement
neutraliser transformant les deux
appareils en avion kamikaze en bombes
volantes george bush s'adresse aux
américains le terrorisme contre notre
nation ne réussira pas maintenant je
vous propose deux jeunes dans un moment
de silence
que dieu bénisse les victimes ou leurs
familles merci quinze minutes plus tard
nouveau scénario catastrophe cette fois
c'est washington qui est la cible le
pentagone est en flammes
percuté par le vol 175 d'unités airlines
à son bord 56 passagers neuf membres
d'équipage
à 10h05 alors qu'un journaliste après
intervenir à l'antenne
la première tour s'effondre
23 minutes plus tard même vision
d'horreur les 110 étages de la seconde
tour s'encastre les uns dans les autres
plus de trente mille personnes sont
prisonnières du béton
une partie new york n'est plus que
poussière est grave
aucune trace de carlingue un trou béant
dans un bois près de pittsburgh le vol
93 d'united airlines en direction de san
francisco s'est crashé à l'envers ce
vide à son bord
38 passagers et sept membres d'équipage
les passagers auraient peut être résisté
aux pirates de l'air empêchant ainsi que
l'avion ne s'écrase sur caen des vides
fragilisé par l'effondrement des deux
tours un immeuble s'effondre en fin
d'après midi
hier soir le soleil couchant ne se
reflétait plus dans le world trade
center de new york
on l'a senti hier que les autorités
américaines étaient complètement
dépassés george bush lui-même a différé
son retour à washington de quelques
heures tant la menace était forte
le président des états unis a promis des
représailles à l'encontre des auteurs de
ces attentats
et aujourd'hui comme vous le disait
serge kovacs il a reçu en fin de matinée
tous les dirigeants des deux chambres du
congrès devant lesquels il va faire une
nouvelle déclaration officielle
gwénaël le noir 9h36 hier george bush
vient d'apprendre la nouvelle première
adresse d'un président sous le choc à
une nation russie le terrorisme contre
notre nation ne passera pas je vous
demande de vous joindre à moi pour une
minute de silence
mes gars savaient que dieu bénisse les
victimes leurs familles et l'amérique
merci beaucoup immédiatement il quitte
la floride le monde entier l'attend à
washington surprise générale l'avion
présidentiel se pose sur une base
militaire en louisiane très loin de la
capitale fédérale
dans une deuxième adresse à la nation il
tient à rassurer malgré tous les
évènements
le gouvernement ne vacille pas notre
armée chez nous et partout dans le monde
et de temps en état d'alerté maximum et
nous avons pris toutes les mesures de
sécurité nécessaires pour que votre
gouvernement continue à travailler
nouveau départ cette fois l'avion
présidentiel a atterri dans le nebraska
sur cette base militaire qui abrite le
commandement stratégique américain
george bush il reste plusieurs heures en
fait les services chargés de sa sécurité
tiennent à vérifier qu'aucun avions
civils ne survolent plus l'espace aérien
avant d'autoriser air force one a
décollé et c'est encadré par des
chasseurs que l'appareil de george bush
relie finalement washington un peu avant
21h heure locale un hélicoptère dépose
le président américain sur la pelouse de
la maison
manche du bureau ovale il menace j'ai
donné l'ordre pour que tout me ressource
en matière de renseignement et de police
il s'attelle à retrouver les
responsables
elle est traduit en justice nous ne
ferons aucune distinction entre les
terroristes qui ont perpétré ces actions
est ce qu'il est aujourd'hui alors que
les etats-unis se réveiller dans un
cauchemar
le président américain le visage grave
prononce le mot de guerre les attaques
délibérées et meurtrières qui ont été
menées hier contre notre pays était plus
que des actes de terreur
elles étaient des actes de guerre des
actes de guerre auquel les américains
veulent répondre ce soir
un sondage indique que 90 % d'entre eux
exigent des représailles à ces attaques
avant d'aller plus loin et pour bien
mesurer l'ampleur de ces actes de guerre
pour reprendre l'expression de george
bush on va revoir comment les habitants
new york ont vécu cette journée du 11
septembre des témoignages poignants
illustré aussi par de nouvelles images
des attentats c'est sans commentaire
montage daniel wolfromm je travaille
tout en bas d'une des fenêtres on peut
voir complètement au feu c'est à dire
quand ça n'allait pas en fait on voit
pas les flammes mais ya une énorme bang
de fumée noire qui s'échappe et fenêtres
sur à peu près 30 étages les 30 derniers
étages de l'immeuble est donc une grande
colonne de fumée noire qui monte
j'ai l'impression que ces genres la tour
infernale le truc on voit vraiment la
fumée qui s'échappe un gros morceau du
truc quoi celle embrasse un laveur de
paris les avions ont le droit de
survoler manhattan donc tu vois souvent
des avions ont survolé le la ville et
moi quand j'ai appelé j'ai peur quand
j'ai vu la fumée d'abord et qu'on
m'annonce ex qu'un avion qui frappe
c'est dedans on sait dire on s'est dit
bon l'accident est arrivé tout le monde
a pensé un accident comme ça un avion
qui s'écrase en et twin towers est un
mets mais de savoir que c'est un acteur
qu'est street terrorisme c'est quand
même hallucinant
après deux grands acteurs de ces camps
explosion un grain de boule de feu
et ensuite dirigés vers l'endroit de
colmont si c'est là il ya un grand se
gaver on a vu tous ces agents de qui
sont sautés de 2,2 et dernier étage de
la world trade center
on aime toujours à voler les jeux
naissance j'étais quittés heureux en
dessous du [ __ ] au dessus de feu
c'était horrible c'est il n'y a pas de
nom pour qualifier ces horribles et on
était tous ceux en état de choc c'est
horrible c'est ça fait comme une
éruption de volcan le tout tout le bas
de la ville est couverte de 2,2 m 2 de
sambre comme s'il y avait un volcan en
éruption
on peut avoir sur la télévision locale
on ne sait pas du tout ce qui s'est
passé
s'il ya des choses qui se passe ailleurs
dans le monde on n'arrive même pas à
concevoir encore que que ça a vraiment
eu lieu de ce matin cette chose assez
horrible et après le deuxième s'est
écroulé alors là les gens hurlaient dans
la rue disait je peux battre paris
pleurait ya des gens qui vomissent ex
tout le monde essayait de téléphoner
mais les lignes téléphoniques marchaient
très mal ça doit être comme ça pendant
la guerre ce pensent à 9 heures tous les
employés étaient présents cc c'est
énorme ça s'est passé aux influences
soul world trade center
c'est une façon c'est une grosse station
de métro et train tous les gens qui
viennent du nu jazz et de soul zaricot
il arrive au wolson factor ce qui fait
qu'il ait énormément de monde à ce
moment là on va pouvoir le 30 heures
c'est terrible terrible c'est
l'imaginaire
heureusement
jour une histoire réconfortante celle de
rescapés qui ont pu que messieurs malgré
leur grand âge survivre aux attentes à
florence fait faux une vieille dame
parmi les survivants roos comptines à 80
ans réfugiée dans un centre de la croix
rouge
elle a bien cru qu'elle serait désormais
seul pour toujours et puis elle a
rencontré sergio un sauveteur à qui elle
a raconté son histoire elle et son mari
ont été séparées au moment de l'attentât
et se trouvait à l'extérieur du world
trade center lui à l'intérieur quand
l'avion s'est écrasé elle a été aussitôt
évacuée dans la panique générale
impossible de résister à la pression de
la foule nous pousser vers le nord tout
au nord
son mari a disparu comme des milliers
d'autres personnes mais certes je ne
veux pas qu'elles perdent espoir il a
tale partout
harry est peut être en vie quelque part
dans la ville les où je suis allé au
bureau des disparus en espérant qu'il
serait là en train de la rechercher mais
il n'y était pas nous ressentons harry
est bel et bien vivant il a réussi à
sortir de la tour et erré pendant des
heures pour finalement trouver refuge
dans une zone protégée
à l'autre bout de la ville la stupeur
passée il laisse un message sur une
boîte vocale help you j'invite prévenir
hausse
harry ou est têtu et jouer les des 1 0
se sont retrouvés pour eux cet avenir
elle ne savait pas si tu étais vivant
j'ai essayé d'y croire et puis je me
disais oh oui oublie ce n'est plus tout
seul et la retrouver son mari et a gagné
nouvelle n est en effet new york apprend
désormais à vivre sans le world trade
center et c'est la ruée vers les objets
souvenirs comme le monde ce reportage de
philippe gassot et christian tu à times
square en plein week-end de septembre on
aura jamais vu si peu de monde
les vendeurs à la sauvette ont connu des
périodes plus fastes
c'est vrai que le touriste se fait rare
il est souvent choqué il c'est quelque
part qu'il a vécu un événement
exceptionnel et qu'il était là mais il
veut quand même rentré chez lui avec la
preuve avec quelque chose à montrer à
ceux qui ont eu peur pour lui
on vend beaucoup des cartes postales des
tours jumelles oui oui ça se vend bien
ceux qui marchent aussi mais c'est plus
cher ce sont les tours sous bulle made
in hong kong qui risque bien de n'être
plus fabriqués dans quelques temps le
modèle en métal ça se vend pas mal et la
bulle ça tombe bien aussi
la première c'est à 5 de la 99 et la
bulle à 6,99 la police habituellement
nombreuses dans les endroits
touristiques de new york a changé de
rôle depuis le drame les problèmes ce
n'est plus le stationnement où les
pickpockets
l'action est plus psychologique notre
rôle c'est d'essayer de veiller à la
sécurité de donner au public
l'impression de sécurité de rassurer les
gens ce qui se vend très bien aussi ce
sont les drapeaux tout le monde en veut
à voir avec soin la bannière étoilée
s'est montré son attachement et sa
volonté de résister au pire mais
fabriquer à la hâte pour une vente
immédiate
le t-shirt du drame que l'on s'arrache à
canal street discutable mais bien
compréhensible c'est un des moments les
plus forts de l'histoire de l'amérique
et dans 20 ans je pourrai dire à mes
enfants que j'étais ici et que j'ai vécu
la tragédie ne cherchait aucune morale
dans tout cela new york n'a jamais
manqué une occasion de se faire de
l'argent
un signe évident de retour à la normale
jusqu'ici on a beaucoup donné la parole
à new york m mais on ignore comment d'or
de manhattan les habitants ont réagi en
ce dimanche isabelle le vestiaire s'est
rendu à la messe dans le new-jersey de
l'autre côté du hudson le trou béant du
world trade center n'en finit pas de
fumée sur les premières hauteurs de new
jazz et le village de russell ford
encaisse le choc
cette paroisse saint georges a perdu un
de ses anciens prêtres et quelques
fidèles dans la catastrophe
nous sommes dans un quartier italien
particulièrement croyant
fois les one c'est 1941 le 7 décembre
pearl harbor qui recommence je pense
qu'on va mettre longtemps à s'en
remettre dans la bonne direction
le président a fait son travail le
congrès il lui a donné des moyens
il ne s'agit pas de simple vengeance ce
qu'ils ont fait aux états unis n'est pas
pardonnable
qu'est ce que vous redoutez maintenant
je ne sais pas j'espère que ça ne va pas
recommencer les américains à tomber ce
premier dimanche après la catastrophe
pour trouver le réconfort religieux dont
ils sont très coutumier pour réfléchir
ensemble prier et dans cette église
franciscaine peut être trouver des
raisons de pardonner
[Musique]
émotion collective tristesse compassion
mais aussi solidarité tous les serments
du pays comme celui du frère bryan ont
rendu hommage aux pompiers policiers
infirmiers secouristes qui ont péri et à
ceux qui luttent encore
mais bon
[Musique]
c'est terrible d'avoir la haine on va à
l'église pour trouver la paix et on a le
coeur plein de haine c'est terrible
alors on prie pour trouver la sérénité
la religiosité le patriotisme des
américains se conforte dans ses temps de
douleur et de ripostes annoncé chacun
ici qu'ont déjà avec la guerre venons en
maintenant à l'anc est proprement dite
et à la traque qui s'est organisée
autour du terroriste milliardaire
séoudiens ben laden comment dans un
premier temps déjà à anéantir une partie
de la puissance des organisations
terroristes placés sous le commandement
réels ou présumés de ce trop fameux
oussama ben laden en tapant porte
monnaie ce milliardaire saoudien possède
toute une kyrielle d'entreprises et de
comptes en banque dans le monde entier
bernard lebrun de michel d'hooghe sa
fascination de l'ennemi grand sens de la
mise en scène et des moyens les plus
sophistiqués
c'était au temps de bill clinton en
pleine montagne afghane des soldats de
ben laden s'entraînent et se motive
offrent leurs cibles privilégiées
propagande bien sûr mais les moyens sont
impressionnants
quatre ans après le premier attentat
dans le sous-sol du world trade center
alors que le fbi et la cia organise une
véritable chasse à l'homme
offrant une prime de cinq millions de
dollars et 10 ans bloqué tous les avoirs
de ben laden
les attentats se poursuivent 1998
attaque en afrique contre les ambassades
américaines du kenya et de tanzanie 230
morts et des centaines de blessés
octobre 2000 attentat suicide dans le
port d'aden contre le destroyer us et
score 19 morts attentats revendiqués
dans cet autre film de propagande dans
un rare ouvrage paru en 1999
l'auteur a longuement enquêté sur la
fortune du fils du milliardaire saoudien
et a tenté de mettre au jour les
circuits financiers de la nébuleuse
islamiste les experts financiers de
l'arab bank association l'association
des banquiers arabe de l'ombre évalue sa
fortune personnelle à plusieurs
milliards de là à 5 ou 6 milliards de
dollars où se trouve cet âge alors cet
argent et est diffusée dans une centaine
plusieurs centaines de sociétés offshore
qui jouissent des paradis fiscaux jersey
guernesey curaçao les îles cayman mais
aussi la suisse et le luxembourg
une fois de plus les paradis fiscaux qui
abrite les sociétés écrans au nom
d'emprunt sont sur la sellette aux
paradis fiscaux sont recensés pour la
seule europe ce matin même en suisse à
lugano
une société financière musulmane du nom
de ta quoi la crainte de dieu en arabe
dont le siège se trouverait au panama a
été inspectée elle aurait servi de
plaque tournante question d'où vient
l'argent d'oussama ben laden est bien de
la spéculation de ses multiples sociétés
offshore de ces centaines de sociétés
dont parfois certaines n'ont que 24
heures d'existence pour faciliter les
transferts de fonds une place financière
à l'autre il sourit osama ben laden
diplômé d'études supérieures économique
et politique
il connaît les faiblesses du système
bancaire occidental sur ces images de
janvier dernier tournait en afghanistan
il mariait son richissime fils azim sa
profession banquier bien sûr ici même à
khartoum capitale de la république
islamique du soudan petits compromis
avec l'histoire
on y vend du coca cola devant la grande
mosquée et huit ans après le premier
attentat contre le world trade center la
banque d'asie mme ben laden a toujours
pignon sur rue
toute la zone est modifié pour vous en
rendre compte
regardez ces images les premières qui
peut être tournée à bord d'un
hélicoptère depuis la catastrophe et qui
permettent donc de se rendre compte de
la modification du quartier manhattan le
quartier des affaires avant et après un
commentaire philippe gassot elle faisait
face à la liberté lune éclairait les
autres reflétait tourner vers le sud
jusque dans les nuages avec 107 étages
11 septembre 2001 plus rien les cendres
un trou un quartier d'affaires
les sociétés financières assurances
avocat 2 millions d'employés
le premier survol en hélicoptère donne
l'étendue des dégâts
c'est l'apocalypse maintenant
symbole de réussite premières places
financières 410 m
pour ceux qui voudraient se souvenir les
deux tours étaient là entre ces deux
images un peu de fumée grise et au moins
5000 bord y aurait-il quelque chose dit
respirable dans l'air de manhattan
depuis qu'ils peuvent à nouveau accéder
au quartier du world trade center
beaucoup de new yorkais n'y vont jamais
sans leur masque si certains en font un
usage inattendue pour la plupart ce
n'est pas juste une coquetterie
ils ne peuvent plus s'en passer
c'est un masque spécial pourquoi parce
qu'il l'a dit filtres spéciaux pour la
poussière pour l'amiante et des trucs
comme ça je vais l'enlever
oui bien sûr le danger est invisible
mais omniprésent dans cette fumée qui
s'échappe des décombres du world trade
center des particules d'amiante les
tours jumelles construite dans les
années soixante dix contenait ce
matériau cancérigène
aujourd'hui c'est le fond de l'air qui
donne des frayeurs
j'ai peut être l'air ridicule comme ça
mais mon père est mort d'un cancer du
nord je veux pas qu'il m'arrive la même
chose à quelques mètres de là dans cet
hôpital les consultations pour problèmes
respiratoires ont augmenté mais les
médecins ne s'attendent pas à faire face
à un grave problème de santé pour deux
passes pour les gens qui passent peu de
temps sur le site il n'y a pas à
s'inquiéter que le niveau des ventes
pour les gens qui travaillent plus
longtemps sur le site comme les
sauveteurs les travailleurs c'est
beaucoup plus préoccupant
les autorités locales et fédérales
affirme que l'ère de manhattan ne
présente aucun danger et qu'il n'y a
aucun risque d'épidémie 6 mai le
ministère de la santé avait dépêché ici
une équipe de 35 médecins spécialistes
par précaution aux etats unis le
discours très galvanisant de george bush
devant le congrès hier soir le président
américain avait sillonné par les
parlementaires a juré solennellement à
l'amérique et au monde de gagner la
guerre contre le terrorisme à washington
etienne leenhardt leinster il est entré
comme un boxeur rentrerai sur un ring
décidés à en découdre et galvanisé par
une foule toute acquise à sa cause
george bush le savez ce discours devant
l'amérique toute entière était sans
doute le plus important de sa carrière
politique il y faudrait à la fois
rassurée et contre-attaqué se comporter
en président mais aussi en chef de
guerre notre peine s'est transformée en
colère et notre colère en détermination
que nous livrions nos ennemis à la
justice ou que nous fassions justice ni
même justice sera faite
l'ont rendu hommage aux victimes en
faisant un triomphe à la jeune épouse
d'un passagers qui s'étaient jetés sur
les pirates de l'air pour tenter
d'éviter le pire
ils ont applaudi à tout rompre le maire
et le gouverneur de new york pour leur
courage et leur détermination à
reconstruire ce qui a été détruit et
l'on se leva encore pour saluer le
premier ministre de grande bretagne et
son soutien sans faille leur est venu
d'engager des représailles et d'exiger
de l'afghanistan des comptes livré aux
états unis tous les terroristes qui se
cachent sur votre sol ces exigences ne
sont ni discutable ni négociable de
l'avis unanime jamais george bush qui va
devoir maintenant passer de la parole
aux actes n'étaient apparus aussi
présidentielle et l'on ne pouvait
s'empêcher de penser hier soir à le voir
serrer dans ses bras l'un des chefs de
l'opposition démocrate qu'il ya six mois
encore cet homme élu dans la douleur
était la risée d'une bonne moitié de
l'année la première comparution du
français zacarias moussaoui devant un
tribunal américain c'est aussi la
première procédure judiciaire qui fait
suite aux attentats du 11 septembre une
procédure de pure forme mais qui a
permis de se rendre compte de l'état
d'esprit de l'accusé etienne leenhardt
aaron dimon sur place
c'était donc pour zakaria ce moussaoui
le premier vrai rendez-vous avec la
justice américaine
arrivé sous bonne escorte très tôt ce
matin le jeune français de 33 ans
apparaît pour la première fois devant
ses juges un uniforme vert de
prisonniers une barbe fournie pas de
menottes aux poignets moussaoui est
calme il écoute sans interprète
plaide-t-il coupable ou non coupable à
la présidente qui lui pose la question
moussaoui debout répond en anglais au
nom d'al là je n'ai rien a plaidé je ne
plais de rien comprenez dire à son
avocat américain qu'il plaide non
coupable
une demi-heure plus tard moussaoui
quitte la salle d'audience sans un
regard pour le public il n'y aurait de
toute façon pas vu sa mère restée à son
hôtel aïcha el wafi n'a pas voulu
risquer en se rendant à l'audience de le
déstabiliser
ça fait longtemps qu'on sait pas vu et
puis s'il me voit moi je sais pas bien
il lui paraît moins va être la même
chose et moi je préfère qu'ils soient
sereins qu'ils répondent à ces questions
qui vous reposer et des questions la
justice américaine en a à revendre
arrêté par hasard pour une histoire de
visa au mois d'août dernier ici dans le
minnesota où il prenait des cours de
pilotage
moussaoui est tout simplement accusé
d'être le 20e pirate de l'air le seul
qui n'ait pu embarquer à bord des avions
détournés si la cour à partir du 14
octobre prochain arrive à prouver qu'il
était directement impliqué dans les
attentats
moussaoui risque la peine de mort et en
faisant juger zacarias moussaoui ici
dans l'état de virginie le gouvernement
américain prend en quelque sorte des
précautions supplémentaires en effet
avec le texas la virginie et l'état
américain dont les jurys populaires
condamne le plus facilement à la peine
capitale
une journée particulière aux états unis
journée de commémoration des attentats
du 11 septembre c'était il ya six mois
jour pour jour
à cette occasion la télévision
américaine cbs a diffusé un film inédit
un film réalisé par deux jeunes français
deux frères venus tourner un
documentaire sur les pompiers de new
york et qui ont donc vécu ce jour-là à
leurs côtés ses deux frères c'est vous
jules et gédéon naudet vous nous en
parlerait dans un instant là précisément
c'est un pompier de new york qui est
assis entre vous deux
un film impressionnant et qui a
évidemment ému les américains ils
étaient 39 millions devant leur poste
hier soir c'est un record
nous allons d'abord en découvrir un
extrait un très large extrait
commentaires pascal golomer notre
correspondant à new york
il devait s'agir à l'origine d'un
documentaire sur l'apprentissage d'un
jeune pompier à manhattan plusieurs
semaines de tournage dans une caserne
ce n'est pas de la rigolade ce boulot où
il faut penser à plein de choses
restez toujours concentré c'est ce qui
te permettra de rester en vie et de
sauver d'autres jeunes
nous sommes le 11 septembre
les pompiers sont appelés pour une
simple fuite de gaz dans la région mena
un contrôle de routine
il est 8 heures 46
et
[Applaudissements]
dès le début j'ai compris que ce serait
la pire journée de ma carrière de
pompier
[Applaudissements]
j'ai su tout de suite que ce n'était pas
un accident mais nous sommes garés à
l'entrée de la tour numéro 1 heure enfin
venue
je lui demande si je peux venir avec
vous quand même il me répond oui mais tu
restes avec moi je viens avec moi je ne
me quitte pas j'entre et j'entends des
cris comme à droite il y a deux grands
enfants
je n'ai pas voulu filmer
je me suis dit personne ne doit voir
cela
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cypher est le premier chef à l'intérieur
de l'immeuble
il organise les secours les pompiers
arrivent calmement qu'il s'apprête à
monter dans les étages avec leurs trente
kilos d'équipement sur le dos beaucoup
ne sortiront pas vivants du wall trade
center lemonnier mychal judge est de
ceux là
c'était la première fois que je voyais
le père jazz avant je voyais qu'il était
en train de prier
deux avions le premier sur la tour
numéro 1 et l'autre vient de s'écraser
sur la deuxième tour
tout le monde regardait la même chose
parler de la même chose
ils réagissaient de la même façon on l'a
vu on l'a vu en avion qu'est ce que les
gens vont faire des ascenseurs sont
bloqués peut-être les escaliers alors
les minutes passent les occupants de la
tour numéro un
puis comme une peur
[Applaudissements]
il est 10 heures 5 un bruit
assourdissant personne parmi les
pompiers ne comprend ce qui se passe
c'est la tour numéro de qui ces fonds
[Applaudissements]
et alors j'ai réagi je me suis dit je ne
suis pas mort j'allume le projecteur sur
ma caméra
[Musique]
il y avait des débris partout dans le
sol était jonché de poussière on regarde
au dessus de nous et on voit la tour
numéro un on se dit tout va bien la tour
est toujours debout et la tour numéro
deux doit être caché derrière personne
ne nous avait rien dit
et puis quelques secondes plus tard
si je sens alors quelqu'un se jeter sur
moi et puis la poussière
[Applaudissements]
il est 13 heures les deux frères se
retrouvent vivant l'un et l'autre plus
rien ne sera plus comme avant
[Applaudissements]
c'était une semaine après les attaques
du 11 septembre le président bush
lançait officiellement la chasse à
l'homme dans le far west on avait
coutume de placardé un avis de recherche
qui disait recherché mort ou vif
tout ce que je veux et tout secret
mairie à veux c'est qu'on l'amène devant
la chatte arrêté oussama ben laden et
démanteler son réseau
tel était l'objectif de l'intervention
militaire américaine en afghanistan
après un an de traque malgré des
semaines de bombardements à tora bora au
nord-est du pays
le chef présumé du réseau al qaïda reste
introuvable le sénat américain demande
des comptes à l'administration bush
nous n'avons toujours pas tuer ni
capturer oussama ben laden est ce que
vous savez au moins où il est bien
évidemment les états unis ne savent pas
où il est
nous savons que rencontrent de grandes
difficultés de fonctionnement
il est peut-être mort il est peut-être
blessé il est peut-être en afghanistan
il est peut-être quelques par ailleurs
d'oussama ben laden les américains n'ont
trouvé en afghanistan qu'un
enregistrement vidéo une cassette qui
auraient été découvertes par hasard à
djalal abad dans son quartier général
déserté sur cette vidéo de mauvaise
qualité rendue publique par le pentagone
le 13 décembre dernier
on y voit ben laden rencontrant un
cheikh saoudien venu lui apporter son
soutien
une rencontre riche en commentaires sur
les attentats du 11 septembre nous
avions calculé à l'avance le nombre de
victimes ennemies qui serais tu es en
fonction de la position de la tour nous
avions calculé que trois ou quatre
étages serait frappé j'étais le plus
optimiste de tous grâce à mon expérience
de terrain
deux semaines après ces révélations le
chef terroriste fait apparaît à l'écran
sur la chaîne qatarie al jazeera cette
fois un enregistrement qui aurait été
expédié par avion au pakistan ben laden
il semble fatigué le visage émacié tord
le bras gauche étrangement immobile il
lance un nouvel appel à la guerre
fantômes les souffrances endurées par le
peuple palestinien
comme pour élargir sa base de soutien
puis c'est une longue éclipse de quatre
mois jusqu'à cette vidéo diffusée le 17
avril par la chaîne arabe mbc une
cassette qui aurait été enregistrée en
décembre dans laquelle ben laden se
félicite des dégâts infligés à
l'économie américaine
le 19 mai c'est au tour du sunday times
de révéler l'existence d'une nouvelle
vidéo du leader d'al qaida obtenu par
l'intermédiaire d'une agence de presse
islamique basée en angleterre ce
document daterait du mois de mars ce qui
prouverait que ben laden était encore
vivant à l'époque le chef terroriste
n'est plus réapparu depuis à l'image les
autorités afghanes le croit caché au
pakistan mon sentiment c'est que le
mollah omar et ben laden sont quelque
part au pakistan
ils sont certainement au nord-est de
l'autre côté de notre frontière avec le
pakistan
le 25 août dernier un site internet
islamiste publié une lettre présentée
comme émanant d'oussama ben laden
un appel à la guerre sainte lancé au
peuple afghan contre les états unis
quand on arrête on t'a frappé quelques
jours plus tard kaboul et des hommes
tentaient d'acheminer le président
afghan hamid karzaï ils y ont vu la
signature d'al qaïda
la menace ben laden aux etats unis la
cia à la recherche d'un pilote soudanais
liés à al qaïda il aurait l'intention de
détourner un avion sur la maison blanche
information du washington times non
confirmées par la cia mais qui nous
rappelle que depuis plus d'un an un
français zacarias moussaoui est
emprisonné en virginie accusé de complot
il est le seul inculpé à ce jour pour sa
participation aux attentats du 11
septembre
son frère vient de publier un livre nous
serons en direct avec lui dans un
instant mais auparavant retour sur le
parcours de zacarias moussaoui
avec magali sert le 14 août 2001 les
responsables de cette école de pilotage
du minnesota alerte le fbi
l'un de leurs élèves zacarias moussaoui
un comportement étrange
les autorités interpelle ce français de
33 ans qui devant les enquêteurs tentent
de dissimuler son identité
finalement zacarias moussaoui est
emprisonné il est en situation
irrégulière sur le territoire américain
le 11 septembre
quatre avions de ligne sont détournés et
s'écrase sur le world trade center le
pentagone et en pennsylvanie le monde
apprend avec stupéfaction que les 19
pirates de l'air avaient suivi des cours
de pilotage aux états unis tout comme
zacarias moussaoui pour le viol d'un
jeune français le 20e pirate de l'air
il est inculpé de complicité de complot
terroriste
il y a six charges retenues contre lui
sont donc quatre de la peine de mort
principal élément à charge détenus par
la justice américaine contre zacarias
moussaoui
ces quatorze mille dollars qu'il aurait
reçu aux états unis de ramzi binalshibh
un homme arrêté il ya quelques jours au
pakistan
il faisait partie de la cellule
d'hambourg par laquelle a transité
mohammed atta ramzi binalshibh avait
aussi lire et de grosses sommes d'argent
à un autre pirate de l'air peu avant les
attentats du 11 septembre le passé de
zacarias moussaoui pèsera aussi devant
les jurés il a séjourné dans des camps
d'entraînement en afghanistan et au
pakistan
le parcours classique des membres d'al
qaïda pourtant au départ tout séparait
zacarias moussaoui de ce monde non
pratiquants il aurait embrassé
l'extrémisme islamiste en angleterre où
il côtoyait les mosquées de findhorn et
baker street
connus pour leurs discours militant
aujourd'hui du fond de sa prison en
virginie
zacarias moussaoui se revendique
esclaves dallas son procès doit débuter
en janvier
il risque la peine de mort les états
unis sur plusieurs fronts renforcent
leur traque du réseau terroriste
d'oussama ben laden avec un succès
certain ces dernières semaines ainsi
l'arrestation la semaine dernière du
financier et du stratège de
l'organisation réfugiés au pakistan et
bien cette arrestation cette double
arrestation a été rendue possible grâce
d'abord à des moyens technologiques
impressionnant auquel il faut ajouter
pour la première fois l'appât du gain 25
millions de dollars pour celui qui les a
dénoncé richard mines et bernard puis ce
sont l'état américain s'apprête à signer
un chèque de 25 millions de dollars
la récompense offerte par le fbi pour la
capture de khaled cheikh mohammed 38 ans
considéré comme le cerveau des
principaux attentats commis par al qaïda
selon la version officielle la traque a
commencé il ya quelques mois
très loin du pakistan près de washington
dans les bureaux de la msa l' agence
nationale de sécurité américaine des
ordinateurs parmi les plus puissants du
monde analysent les communications
interceptées par satellite
c'est le système échelon toujours selon
les autorités américaines
sheikh mohammed possédait 10 portable
qu'il utilisait fréquemment
cela avait permis de localiser l'un de
ses interlocuteurs à quoi tu as au
pakistan un égyptien que les services
secrets ont convaincu de coopérer
moyennant récompense 25 millions de
dollars plus une rallonge de 2 millions
pour se rendre en grande bretagne une
version un peu trop belle pour être
vraie selon les spécialistes du
renseignement
ce sont surtout les services secrets
pakistanais qui ont aidé à sa capture
ils ont une connaissance très précise
factuel des lieux de cash des modes de
communication comment ces gens là opère
donc ce type de renseignements est
beaucoup plus déterminants pour arrêter
quelqu'un du calibre de khaled cheikh
mohammed
que de penser qu'il va se trahir par
sont vulgaires téléphone portable grand
mérite de la version officielle elle
évite au pakistan d'apparaître en
première ligne dans l'arrestation de
cheikh mohammed et peut faire douter al
qaïda de la totale fidélité de ses
troupes
voilà messieurs bonsoir choisi
personnellement par ben laden et seul
accusé par la justice américaine pour
complicité dans les attentats du 11
septembre
zacarias moussaoui plaide coupable ce
français arrêté peu avant les attaques
contre les tours jumelles a reconnu
qu'il s'était entraîné à frapper la
maison blanche
cette détermination à reconnaître les
faits du évite un procès alors que
certains évoquent une santé mentale
fragile
moussaoui risque la peine de mort a
lancé levant r'n'b hamad dans ce 4 4 aux
vitres fumées
zacarias moussaoui arrive au tribunal
d'alexandria près de washington s'était
dit hier 15 heures deux jours plus tôt
il avait fait venir la présidente de la
cour dans sa prison j'ai l'intention de
plaider coupable lui avait-il dit
va-t-il maintenant réitéré ses aveux
dans une audience publique
le franco-marocain seul inculpé dans les
attentats du 11-septembre a déjà avoué
dans le passé puis il s'était rétracté
mais là d'emblée il réaffirme sa
culpabilité et donne même des détails
c'est ben laden en personne qui m'a
demandé d'aller fracassé un avion sur la
maison blanche
mais c'était un autre complot que 11
septembre où sa wii semble fier de se
dépeindre en héros du djihad
sélectionnés par le chef vous rendez
vous compte des conséquences de ce que
vous dites demande la magistrate
tout à fait répond moussaoui qui signe
immédiatement des aveux détaillés
ses avocats plaident contre la vie de
leurs clients les responsabilités ces
aveux n'ont aucune valeur distille pas
du tout tranché la juge moussawi est
intelligent et connaît la loi je le
déclare coupable
aussitôt le ministre de la justice
triomphe
cinq thèmes saint-louis le fait que
moussaoui et participé à un complot
terroriste n'est plus mise en doute
et plus que jamais nous demandons la
peine de mort en espèces
quant aux familles des victimes du 11
septembre elle voit déjà moussaoui sur
une chaise électrique
annie pelletier gâte quelle que soit sa
peine il l'aura mérité est ce que nous
demandons la peine de mort absolument
dans les semaines ou les mois qui
viennent un jury populaire devrait être
constituée qui déterminera à la peine
peine qui pourrait donc bien être la
mort les en dissociant ses aveux du 11
septembre
zacarias moussaoui espère sans doute
avoir enfoncé un coin dans la si
complexe procédure
r américaine zacarias moussaoui est donc
définitivement fixé sur son sort à 37
ans il va passer le reste de ses jours
dans une cellule de 7 mètres carrés
insonorisé sans contact avec les autres
avec une heure de sortie par jour c'est
le régime de tous les détenus dans la
prison de haute sécurité qui va
l'accueillir dès ce soir avant d'être
emmené le français a défié une dernière
fois le tribunal en bénissant oussama
ben laden sur place aux états unis alain
de chalvron parce qu'elle joue friot
c'est la dernière fois que la presse se
massent ainsi devant le tribunal
d'alexandria l'ultime acte du procès
moussaoui vient de se jouer au septième
étage de cet immeuble
la juge a confirmé tout simplement à
l'accusé sa sentence prison à vie sans
libération possible
ultime provocation de l'intéressé dieu
sauve ben laden vous ne l'attrapé jamais
amérique écoute nous reviendront un jour
le verdict a surpris on attendait la
mort mais il n'y a pas eu consensus
parmi les jurés trois d'entre eux ont
estimé que moussaoui n'aurait joué qu'un
rôle mineur dans les attentats va donc
pour la perpétuité
les familles de victimes sont résignés
je crois qu'il va pourrir en prison
et chaque jour qu'il passera sans voir
la lumière et sans liberté sera un autre
jour de victoire pour nous un verdict
qui sonne comme une défaite pour le
procureur qui espérait bien la mort
regrets aussi à demi mots du président
bush ils ont sauvé sa vie
mais ce n'est pourtant pas ce qu'il a
fait avec la vie de citoyen américain
est innocent
la presse dans son ensemble salue une
décision juste et courageuse et se
félicite que les jurés n'est pas céder à
l'émotion aux insultes de l'accusé
zacarias moussaoui devrait donc vivre le
restant de ses jours
dans cette prison de haute sécurité du
colorado surnom l'alcatraz ce des
rocheuses car on s'en échappe pas il
passera 23 heures sur 24 dans une
cellule de 3,5 sur deux mètres dans une
situation d'isolement total sans voir
les autres prisonniers les principaux
criminels ou terroristes condamnés aux
états unis sans courrier ni téléphone ni
visite un cul de basse-fosse aseptisé
ainsi est donc terminé le premier procès
du 11 septembre les américains ont
encore entre leurs mains quelque part on
ne sait où plusieurs gros gibier d'al
qaïda y notamment l'organisateur des
attentats cheikh khaled mohamed voudront
ils le faire passer en justice
rien n'est moins sûr new york dont les
habitants auront sans doute écouté avec
beaucoup d'attention les révélations
entre guillemets de celui qu'on présente
comme le cerveau des attentats du 11
septembre khaled cheikh mohammed
numéro 3 d'al qaïda a été interrogé pour
la première fois à guantanamo il
revendique l'attentât mais aussi une
trentaine d'autres détails également
certains projets d'assassinât contre
bill clinton ou jimmy carter des aveux
qui suscitent le doute
christelle bertrand aujourd'hui on ne
sait pas de quoi il a l'air cette photo
de khaled cheikh mohammed a été prise
lors de son arrestation en 2003 depuis
il est tenu au secret par les américains
dans des aveux rendue publique par le
pentagone il déclare être responsable
des attentats du 11-septembre de a à z
khaled cheikh mohammed ne s'arrête pas
là il décrit comment en février 2002 il
a lui même décapité daniel pearl
le journaliste américain enlevé au
pakistan l'ex numéro trois du réseau al
qaïda chef des opérations militaires
revendique aussi l'attentât à la bombe
dans une discothèque de bali où 200
personnes sont tuées en tout khaled
cheikh mohammed reconnaît avoir signé 30
et une opération terroriste
il avouait tout cela à guantanamo la
prison militaire américaine sur l'île de
cuba
il y est détenu depuis septembre dernier
toutes les informations de cette
première audition ne sont livrés que par
l'armée américaine
aucun avocat aucun témoin civile n'a
assisté à ces aveux l'homme aux
multiples visages affirme avoir voulu
assassiner bill clinton jimmy carter et
jean paul ii khaled cheikh mohammed et
comme l'appellent les américains
un prisonnier de haute valeur qui
pourrait bientôt être traduits devant un
tribunal militaire d'exception
il était
2h46 quant à sonner le glas ce matin à
new york
8h46 c'est exactement l'heure à laquelle
le premier avion a percuté la tour nord
du world trade center il ya six ans la
ville a honoré la mémoire de ces
victimes et la cérémonie était plus
sombre que d'habitude
george bush par exemple était resté à
washington sur place marit martine
laroche-joubert pascal souffrir 8h46 ce
matin le son du glas raisonne sur ground
zero une minute de silence commence
c'est l'heure à laquelle le premier
avion percute la tour nord du world
trade center il y a 6 ans pour la
première fois les commémorations se
déroule en retrait du site en travaux
[Musique]
les sauveteurs tu les parents des
victimes
liste à tour de rôle les noms des deux
mille sept cent quarante neuf personnes
qui trouvent la mort dans l'effondrement
des tours
la douleur est intacte
[Musique]
mon frère charles était très attentif
aux autres
c'était aussi un fils aimant une
cérémonie plus discrète que les années
plus suivante les un ciel gris et une
pluie fine souligner davantage encore la
tristesse des familles elles seules sont
autorisées à descendre à l'intérieur du
site où leurs proches ont disparu des
fleurs en eau froide
un site marquée aussi par la mort la
maladie des sauveteurs sans protection
pour déblayer les décombres
six ans après le 11 septembre
80% des américains considèrent ces
attentats comme l'événement historique
le plus important de leur vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]